myanmar's ousted leader aung san soo chi
is back in court today facing a new
trial for alleged corruption
the pro-democracy leader has faced a
long list of charges since her
government was overthrown by a military
coup in february the junta has ramped up
violence to try and crush a popular
uprising the u.n is warning that the
window of opportunity to stop the army
from entrenching his rule is growing
smaller by the day
the people protest
the military cracks down
it's a cycle that's been repeated many
times in myanmar's history
most recently earlier this year the
military deposed the country's fledgling
democratic government in february and
arrested its leaders including aung san
tsuchi
since then she's been under house arrest
facing a wide array of charges including
incitement the deliberate spreading of
misinformation to agitate the people
violating covet 19 restrictions
and illegally importing walkie-talkies
to be used by her supporters
if found guilty the 76 year old could
face decades in prison
meanwhile the human rights situation in
myanmar has deteriorated rapidly since
the coup
over 1
100 individuals have reportedly now died
at the hands of the security forces
since the coup
over 8 000 individuals including
children have been arrested since the
coup with over 4 700 remaining in
detention
most are held without any form of due
process and lack access to legal counsel
or even the ability to communicate with
their families
the military government faces increasing
international isolation
and a cratering economy that's seen
widespread shortages with a humanitarian
crisis looming
the un has called for sushi's immediate
release as a first step towards
restoring order
yet her trial is set to go ahead
as resistance in the streets continues
despite the government's harshest
efforts to suppress it
for more now i'm joined by pulitzer
prize-winning journalist amen tun who's
currently based in bangtan bangkok good
to see you again first of all those
charges against aung sang su chi her
supporters say they're trumped up that
the case is politically motivated how do
you see it
so what we're seeing from the hunter now
is the persecution of top political
leadership in myanmar
under a host of charges the most recent
space of charges has been
for corruption we've seen various
ministers and
local government leaders charged with
corruption with very little evidence to
show
how they could have committed these
crimes or that these crimes indeed took
place
i think in the case of outside sushi we
also need to look at some of the other
things that she has been charged with
one of which is incitement of public
unrest which uh with the hunters citing
the public's response to the coup as
evidence of her crime and yet with her
we see that she was arrested on the very
first day of the coup in the pre-dawn
air in the pre-dawn of hours and so it's
very difficult to see how she could have
committed at least this crime which uh
obviously brings uh into question the
legitimacy of many of these other
charges that she is being
held
without
very little access to our lawyers
and in an unknown location for
following the full military takeover
there were massive protests that were
violently crushed what has become of
that protest movement
yeah so in the first few weeks of the
protest we saw hundreds of thousands if
not millions of people in the streets
and we saw that you know people really
faced the the high risk of death
for conducting those protests so what
we're seeing now is a
nationwide protests are still ongoing
however they take the form of these
small flash strikes that are happening
in various cities and towns across the
country
they're largely organized to be less
than you know 10 or 20 minutes
and they are sort of very ad hoc and
involve very few people in order for
people to be able to continue to show
the world that they do not consent to
this form of government um and yet are
trying to stay safe we are also seeing a
continuation of the civil disobedience
movement which has seen over a hundred
thousand civil servants who are
continuing to strike and continuing to
refuse to work for the hunter many of
whom are now in hiding as the junta has
been trying to sort of hunt down these
striking workers people are continuing
to boycott military-owned and affiliated
companies and we've also seen a civil
government that has risen up and
declared themselves to be the legitimate
government of myanmar but we are
definitely seeing a decrease in uh
in-street protest as
these forms of resistance become more
and more dangerous
now the u.n secretary general this week
gave a stark warning about the myanmar
crisis he said there's a risk of
large-scale armed conflict and what he
called a multi-dimensional catastrophe
what is he do you have any idea what
he's referring to there
yeah so myanmar is technically at war
at the moment the the civilian
government i was just talking about the
national unity government has declared
what they're calling a people's
defensive war uh
calling on the people of the country to
fight against the military so what we're
seeing now is more and more armed
clashes taking place
between uh local non-military militias
uh against the military we're seeing a
number of targeted assassinations as
well as the use of bombs and land mines
and
really we're seeing a stalemate in which
the military is unable to fully repress
uh the people and the armed insurrection
that is taking place across the country
right now and these local militias are
largely unable and do not have the
firepower to actually defeat the
military
and you know on top of the fact that
there is now essentially a war that's
taking place across the country myanmar
was already a fairly poor country to
begin with with weak healthcare
infrastructure as well as education
infrastructure and there's a real risk
that millions of people could fall into
food insecurity in the coming months
and economists are predicting a
double-digit contraction in the economy
in the next year
journalist ayman tan there in bangkok
thank you very much
thank you for having me
you